news of a ps4 price drop in Japan
recently came to light and Xbox boss
bill Spencer has suggested that a
Western price drop may not be far behind
Spencer insinuated that Microsoft have
predicted this sort of thing before as
he explained to IGN I fully expect
PlayStation will drop price when I think
about the PlayBook they've used in the
past we feel good about the plans we
have in place going forward in holiday
if history told then we'll see a price
drop from them coming the ps4 has kept
its launch price of 400 bucks since its
server 2013 launch while the xbox one
debuted at five hundred dollars with a
compulsory Kinect camera but later
dropped to 400 and then again to 350 for
the base models and connect Sony's next
major announcement event will be the
paris game show in october which Spencer
did name drop in his interview although
that doesn't confirm that we will hear
about a ps4 price drop next month let me
know down in that comment section if you
think the ps4 is due for a price drop
this story and everything else that
matters in gaming be sure to stay tuned
the game spot